despite being the kind of nail biter
we've come to expect from The Walking
Dead the series finale didn't go down
well with everyone here are the moments
from the final episode that upset people
the most near the end of the
Commonwealth storyline Daryl does
something that fans of TV shows either
love or hate he says the name of the
show in a brief dramatic well as
dramatic as Daryl ever gets speech to
Pamela and the Commonwealth soldiers he
gruffly says we need The Walking Dead
any boss walks toward the gates without
another thought it's a cool moment that
a lot of fans ate it up Twitter ran
rampant with reactions to the line a lot
of which were positive however there
were plenty of tweets making fun of the
title drop and some people flat out
hated it one user tweeted Daryl just
said The Walking Dead and a dramatic
build up and I'm reminded why I stopped
watching this dog show it's a clear
callback to Rick Grimes in season five
that we are The Walking Dead
Easter egg or not Norman Reedus revealed
to Vanity Fair that he had to be talked
into it he said I had to figure out a
way to just make it part of the sentence
without making it a poster after 12
years of The Walking Dead killing off
main characters and practically being
driven by death it's why they accepted
that no one is safe we've seen beloved
characters take their leave including a
number of children one issue with the
finale is that spin-offs have already
been announced so a number of the
survivors like Daryl Maggie and Negan
were at no real risk of being killed off
while all fans have characters they root
for most were expecting to see a bit
more Bloodshed on Reddit the general
consensus seems to be that the finale
lacked any meaningful deaths one user
wrote it should have gone bigger with
the deaths really made us feel like none
of our favorite characters were safe
another bone fans have depict with the
finale was how it handled the Lost
members of Magnus group The Writers
brought Luke and Jules back seemingly
out of nowhere just to abruptly kill
jewels and kick off the finale by
killing Luke there's no denying that the
heavily emotional death of Luke still
reeling over the loss of his girlfriend
and in pain from the loss of his leg
started the episode out with a bang that
seemed to promise a finale that takes no
prisoners Luke would turn out to be one
of the only survivors to die though
which makes his son return an Abrupt
exit feels somewhat sacrificial many
fans saw Luke's death as nothing more
than a way to squeeze some gore in
without killing off a main character one
commenter wrote y'all did loot dirty
while another said that the writer
shouldn't have bothered bringing Luke
back if it was to kill him off
the series finale is full of callbacks
including the way Judith wakes up on a
hospital bed this is how the series
began with her father waking up in a
deserted Hospital back in the first ever
episode while the nostalgic parallel was
nice many fans think that since the
series opened with Rick it should have
closed on him too it's true that a lot
of fans on Reddit have said that Rick
was present in more of the finale than
they expected which is a great thing
however there are those who wanted to
handle differently one user wrote at at
least one a 10-minute scene so we could
get a proper look at where both he and
Michonne was or just anything just a
proper scene with both of them even if
separate this was just an extended
version of what I thought we were
getting it was nice seeing them anyways
but man I'm Dead AMC for not bringing
back his storyline during the season
others thought the Rick scenes were a
letdown according to a second user it
was strange and Faded in and out I had
no idea what was going on fans missed me
shown after deny Guerrera exited the
Walking Dead Following Season 10. many
people wanted and expected her to pop up
in the finale to help her fellow
survivors out of another tight spot
Michonne has always had a way of coming
out of nowhere to save the day just like
she did with the formula for Judith all
the way back at the prison so it makes
sense that she would return to play some
part in the curtain closer and if it's
me who doesn't make it you're gonna have
to lead the others forward
her presence in the finale isn't what
upset fans people didn't like the way
she was dressed Michonne has always
looked great no matter who she's
fighting or how covered in blood she
gets but her appearance in The Walking
Dead finale had fans scratching their
heads Michonne is spotless and wearing
intricate fighting Leathers which led
fans to wonder where the heck she got
her clothes many noted that Denai
Guerrero looked more like Okoye or
Marvel character one fan commented yeah
when I saw Michonne's outfits I thought
that I was in the middle of shooting
wakanda forever and dropped by for a
quick appearance on the Walking Dead
without changing costumes LOL
as the only Survivor from the main group
who's been around for a long while
Rosita's death was hard to take unlike
many of the other main characters deaths
we've seen in the series hers wasn't
bloody she gets bitten after falling
into a group of Walkers with the newly
recovered baby Coco strapped to her
chest after a series of badass Maneuvers
get the child to safety Rosita reveals
she's been bitten on the back it's
typical for The Walking Dead to handle a
main character death with a short-lived
High marred by a tragedy the fans just
aren't buying the sequence of events
leading to Rosita's death in fact
Digital Spy called Rosita's and the
dumbest death in the entire series a lot
of fans agreed and we can't really blame
them because not much about it makes
sense for one thing the placement of her
bite seems off considering that she's
wearing numerous layers of clothing
there's also the fact that she's unable
to make a jump that Eugene made before
her even though she's leagues ahead of
him in physical ability and is one
redditor pointed out her actual passing
was unconvincing they didn't do a good
job making her look sick she looked
totally fine and then she just closed
her eyes the three previously in
announced Walking Dead spin-offs while
good news for fans proved problematic
for the finale of the original series
first knowing that most fan favorite
characters couldn't be killed off
drastically lowered the stakes to make
matters worse the pending spin-offs
influenced the finale in terms of the
story for some fans the send-off episode
was too much like a backdoor pilot for
future shows rather than giving a solid
satisfying ending to the original series
fans were quick to call the show out for
this over on Reddit one user writes it's
like hey you will get to see what
happens but only if you keep watching
our other shows it's like releasing a
video game but the final boss is locked
behind DLC it's really a behavior while
it certainly makes sense to touch on
where the fan favorite characters have
been and are heading in the finale
squeezing in intros to three separate
spin-offs is a bit much we are endless
partially because of how much Focus the
finale gave the upcoming spin-offs the
last episode of the long-running series
wasn't a true finale at all even though
the series was ending it was really just
a new beginning it's almost as if
production was afraid to get fans true
closure in case they wouldn't want to
continue watching the future spin-offs
Forbes senior contributor and author
Paul tassey called a lot of the creative
decisions and some of the more emotional
scenes cheap I think of the Dead
all the time
and about the living
who I lost according to Tassie these
scenes were there to give the episode
more of a finale feel but in truth the
episode lacked any real shocks or twists
we have a lot to be proud of my friends
it's our family our community
[Music]
future Tassie definitely isn't alone in
this opinion to call something that
spends half its time talking up future
storylines a finale has been labeled a
cop-out by a lot of fans there's an
ongoing joke on Reddit about how the
series will never really end in the
words of one user all these spin-offs
will eventually cross over into a major
event called The Walking Dead season 12
one day don't keep making it better
[Music]
you will too while another user added
Walking Dead epilogue the movie and it's
a Trilogy another way the impending
spin-offs affected the finale is that
the inclusion of so much setup made the
rest of the episode feel rushed this
isn't just a finale problem though the
entire Commonwealth plot that ended the
show wasn't as well put together as it
should have been according to CBR
production was forced to rush the
Commonwealth plot line despite it being
a huge undertaking the Speedy run
through the storyline did the finale
note favors as collider put it the
episode felt rushed and chaotic at times
you disappeared hundreds of citizens led
the dead to our doorstep
we shot a child with so many survivors
and story lines coming together ticking
every box was always going to be tricky
in the end the finale contained too many
leaps of logic an example of this is
trying to nullify the threat of zombies
by blowing up a portion of the
Commonwealth how is this a quick fix
solution one thing that never seemed to
write about the Commonwealth storyline
is that we never really see the place
the Commonwealth is supposed to be made
up of around 50 000 survivors yet we
never see just how expansive and diverse
the community really is the only
plausible explanation was that the
creators were waiting for the finale to
unleash the full scale of the
Commonwealth and its population which
never happened leaving fans underwhelmed
one redditor writes like honestly there
were not a single moment in the show
where we could feel that the
Commonwealth had at least 200 people in
it another user claimed that the lack of
numbers in these big scenes was a
hangover from covid-19 restrictions
writing once they knew they could get
away with less people in every scene
they stuck with it ruin the sense of
community and really fails to bring the
point to purpose home
considering how much The Walking Dead
focuses on the themes of family and
loyalty the survivors sure do leave
their kids behind a lot it obviously
takes a village to raise a child in a
zombie apocalypse we get that however
all the child abandonment becomes a bit
too much when parents go off on their
own missions leaving their young ones
behind for the foreseeable future Carol
yeah
we deserve a happy ending too the Grimes
children don't see a lot of their
parents while RJ and Judith are lucky to
have seasoned survivors as parental
figures it doesn't matter much when
they're not around as one concerned
redditor put it every adult that's
supposed to care for them doesn't die
doesn't get sick they just bail another
user doubled down with Judith and RJ
must have debilitating abandonment
issues to the degree that RJ has only
spoken a few words since Mom split for
many fans on Reddit the biggest problem
with the finale is a lack of closure as
one commenter put it what exactly did we
get closure on other than Mercer and
Ezekiel running the Commonwealth while
another user added there's no payoff
nothing is resolved and a third piled on
with an excellent point five years ago
we would have thought that the series
would end with complete closure such as
apocalypse over and cure found however
with the spin-offs planned they
obviously can't do that we're together
pieces
hold
that you're going for what we gave each
other one Unstoppable life or
recognizing the finale's good moments
vultures episode recap focuses on the
lack of solid closure and comments on
the Oddity of having the finale end with
the promise of a bright future while
also preparing us to see the spin-off
survivors living through more struggles
I want to talk about the future there's
a lot out there to find out about
I think it's time we did it's like the
finale veins closure but there's
actually none given